that he's gotten into fashion lately
what is that rumor I think that's uh
they're the memes right online people
just say that all the time in the chat
uh he might be into fashion but it's
clear that he's still into the chess and
we do have liftoff so the game is
underway here we go game two you guys
between all the rest of food shop and
arches I see um he might be into fashion
but you guys should get into Panda 3 I
mean
1d4 on the boy I love it nailed it again
and uh it's a London system
are we allowed to boo openings here in
the studio is that because it's a boring
opening I just think that it creates a
situation that is a slower build up you
know it's not going to be a game oh
maybe it'll show differently but it's
usually kind of a calmer start to these
positions yeah I think we're only
allowed to do the London system the
French and maybe the Berlin
anything else is off limits those three
fair game but uh yeah it has made a
version pause for thought I'm very
surprised I must confess because Eric
icy has been dabbling in the London
system quite a lot over the last year or
so he's also been playing the draba
London uh many times he used it against
Magnus for example in the world rapid
Championship so uh this surely shouldn't
have come as a surprise if ferrugia was
doing his preparation but maybe he was
just thinking new match situation I'm
down a point I want to play for a win I
can't just choose a solid option I can't
just play for a draw in this one so
farouza uh his light squared Bishop over
there on the queen side I was about to
say could we be going towards a queen's
Indian type of setup but D6 there
pushing a pawn just blocking the London
Bishop the white Dart Square Bishop
there very sensible he's getting ready
to bring more pieces out and just uh
keeping Eric I see guessing here it's
very much out of the Realms of theory
here it's just about who understands the
plans the setups better in the ensuing
middle game I also like how flexible
both players have kept their structures
black and also fanchato the other Bishop
I was just about to say from the King
side G6 and the bishop lands on this
long diagonal white not committing the C
Pawn so here Arjun is deciding whether
he wants to put it to C3 or to C4 for a
more aggressive approach in the center
first we might see Eric icy just get his
King to safety and get the white king
castle with London system players they
follow a tried and tested method here a
system in the opening they just want to
put the white Bishop out maybe on E2 get
the white king castled drop the dart
Square Bishop back and then start
playing chess and then start playing the
game the London system not everyone's
favorite loads of memes out there for it
but hopefully this one will liven up at
some point yep
We are following the second game Arjun
Eric icy is in the lead and I've seen a
bunch of yourself he's popping up on the
screen as well we do love to see that
you guys joining in on the action share
your selfie on Twitter using the hashtag
chess Champs and every day during the
air things monsters we will pick a
selfie winner off an air things device
it's actually signed by Magnus Carlsen
himself so enter the competition by
sharing your selfie we want to see where
in the world you're watching the chess
from who you're watching it with
is it late at night is it early in the
morning for you wherever you are in the
world share your selfies so if I share a
selfie of who I'm watching with yeah the
three of you yeah do I automatically win
you don't automatically win but you
automatically enter the competition
we'll fix it so that you don't win
we might also be able to hook you up
with an air thanks device I appreciate
that yeah and we'll talk about that more
throughout the event but air quality we
have found in past seasons in past years
that it has had a direct effect on the
players uh the quality of their play and
we've seen Magnus Carlsen play well when
he's got great air quality Anish giri
really lives so he kind of swears by the
air things device so hopefully whoever
gets it in the end will use it yeah and
benefit their chess I mean so important
for chess players with the online chess
playing from their homes to have good
air quality if CO2 levels are super high
it's gonna be hard to concentrate for
sure and something else that needs air
is someone's position and you see the
last that was played the pawn push in
the center gives some air to the black
pieces and it looks like Arjun he
decides to hop forward with his Knight
he's keeping the tension that's
something very instructive in chess you
don't release the tension until the
moment you feel is ready because you
don't just want to take a piece as it is
simply offered but it this does give
black the opportunity to push that
Central Pawn forward and create an
attack towards the white king so it's
going to be an interesting battle here I
think just the type of position that
alireza could hope for out of a London
system yeah and the debate is always as
Robert mentions when to push this Pawn
forward or if to push the spawn forward
because yes you can gain some time
actually he doesn't go for this he
captures the pawn but uh after the White
Knight steps back the dot squared Bishop
the London Bishop actually gains in
power gains an influence along this
diagonal long term and unless you can
actually go for this King and Checkmate
it then often this is something that may
backfire instead farouza slightly
surprisingly to me captures this Pawn
this is something we don't often see uh
in the London system too much now white
I'm assuming recapture it this way and
there will be a semi-open C file for the
white Rook later still the same issue of
this dark Square Bishop having a
watchful gaze over this diagonal this
does happen and ferricia says okay
you've got a slightly more open position
now I'm going to lock down the queen
side I'm going to fix the pawn structure
here Lex pawns are going to stay in this
formation for I think uh forever if they
can and play will switch towards the
central squares black is maybe going to
plant a knight on this nice E4 square
and start pushing some pawns towards the
white king from your London experience
London system experience guys sir what
do you think is this
well who's this going to favor this
portrait I'm surprised I must say
I like what alireza has done with this
Pawn trade and I think it was uh it was
encouraged by white move pushing that a
pawn to A4 and this is the point that I
was going to make David that the Knight
can't jump to B4 as well because white
spawn has all all the way gone up to A4
you don't have to move A3 pushing that
night so the B4 square is a super nice
Square for your knight to land on so yes
you want to trade in the center forcing
white while not forcing when white wants
to pick that pawn up with the c Pawn as
he did but in that bargain you kind of
give up control over this B4 square and
that's what alireza is fighting for so a
nice idea there okay interesting stuff
although I might say that the pawn push
that other is made to pushing upon to A5
I think that gave white some ground
because just like you're bringing the
Knight into B4 white can bring the
Knight via A3 up to B5 and the big
problem for black is you can't touch
either the c or the d-pawn if you push
the C Pawn you lose the pawn on D6 if
you push the d-pawn eventually up to D5
if the Knight moves out the way then C7
will be a quick Target so I feel feel
like that move A5 was one of those just
small moves that has a big consequence
consequences for both sides certainly
and uh let's go back to the players I do
expect them because this is a more
maneuvering type of battle to spend
quite a lot of time I do notice
especially in the rapid format players
tend to invest their time when there's
lots of different plans to choose from
when it comes to calculation they're so
quick that they make decisions very very
fast and they're usually right so uh
here where there's no right or wrong
answer where it's just a matter of taste
a matter of style and they do tend to
tank for a while so Eric I see now down
three minutes on the clock this is kind
of a reverse of the first game between
these guys when it was far Asia and his
clock handling that cost him but wow
peace sacrifice and Hanya your first
instinct was what he's given up a bishop
he's London Bishop for two Pawns that is
the bishop that you you just love this
is the reason you play the London and he
gives it up well the idea is clear
you're hitting that Rook on E8 you're
hitting that Bishop on B7 uh and black
has to answer the question has to give
back some material here do you there's
one interesting idea that does exist
Queen B8 defending that saying that you
take the bishop you take the Rook on E8
but I get two pieces in return and it
looks like it might be enough for black
I am shocked at this decision David yeah
and if we do a quick count now we do see
that white has partnered with a bishop a
knight that's worth six points black
however has parted with a rook and two
pawns with seven so kind of if we do a
bit of maths white should be ahead but
top chess players they often prefer the
pieces rather than the rook and pawns
here White's Rooks one of them is okay
on the open C file the other one faster
sleep at home white pawns can't really
advance and often it actually helps
having more pieces here black having the
nine and Bishop because uh if you do
whip up an attack later on two pieces uh
will be better than one and Robert what
do you think of this committal decision
by white well Big Choice from originary
guys tonight I'm used to trusting him
he's such a strong player that he would
not make the sacrifice he hadn't looked
at a similar type of sacrifice in the
past but what we're saying certainly
holds true that the two minor pieces can
team up on a square or on a piece and
Rook is only one piece it's gonna be
difficult to defend so for now I like
White's position I think everything is
nice and neat but I could see a future
where black just improves piece by piece
and then white will not be able to deal
with it because there are no more
Targets in Black's position what are you
going to go after everything is safe and
sound so I do feel like as this game
continues its side who has the better
plan that is gonna have the advantage
yeah so this one despite the evaluation
bar being roughly in the middle it could
go either way later on and
I I kind of love and hate that decision
I hate it because I would never be brave
enough to play something like this
myself because it now it's so imbalanced
it's so complex but I also love it from
a Fan's point of view because this one
is going to be anything but a draw this
one uh it could go either way especially
if as we predict it's very likely at
this point Black's pieces do start to
improve do start to mobilize and whites
Rock if it can't use the openc file uh
it will feel uh like a bit of a silly
piece so yeah all to play for in this
one all to play fun black needs to watch
out because white has got a devious
threat right now because white wants to
push off that Knight on D5 with the move
like E4 notice how The Queen 98 cannot
pick up that pawn on e4 because the
Knight on D7 is hanging and uh then
you'll be forced to move that Knight and
White Strip can jump to C7 which is why
alireza takes the decision to move the
Rook to the center of the board
defending the D7 Knight so that if you
do go E4 now the black queen is free to
capture the pawn yeah it's free to
capture the pawn and importantly the
Knight is defended so yeah hidden threat
that I had actually missed that one
Tanya but of course these top players
they do spot those ideas and nice
defensive move there from farrugia if
we're talking about white improving
pieces maybe you can finally utilize
this Rook try to start motoring your
pawns up the board you have to use your
pawns remember you do have two more of
them uh if you're white here than black
does but it's not going to be easy for
example if you do move the Rook to
support a pawn push black can clamp down
on that one maybe push the F Pawn to
control that square maybe occupy that
square with the queen a bunch of options
and uh yeah it's hard as we mentioned to
get this Rook into its dream post on C7
for now because it's protected by a
knight but watch out for Eric I see
trying to tactically enable that
maneuver a bit later on so we are
expecting this now to be an interesting
battle I was gonna ask right before Air
Guys he made those huge decisions if we
should switch games because I could see
on the bars in the other games that may
maybe Magnus Carlsen is struggling
against Alexa sorana if you've seen that
game Robert he is I was looking at the
game at the corner of my eye and for
Magnus Carlson he won with the white
piece in game one very convincingly here
in game two it looks like Serana if you
if you didn't show the audience who had
what color you might think that Magnus
Carlsen had the white pieces because
it's just a clear Advantage for Alexa he
is playing very well in the second game
all right and uh Hikaru Nakamura though
the bar all the way uh well it's over to
his side against yukashi won the first
game Hikaru Nakamura and you guys shout
out if we have to switch games but it
does sound like there will be a lot of
action in this one it feels like for now
this is the place to be but we will keep
keep you guys updated I should also
mention with Serana in the play-ins he
went seven for seven with white wow and
in the world Blitz he beat Nakamura and
Carlson with white so those are the
games he's banking on he's relying on he
needs to win those ones uh with black as
we saw in in game one of the day
he does struggle a bit he didn't score
so well and his black repertoire maybe
not sir as bulletproof as uh he is with
the white pieces and Carlson just wants
to survive that one but it's going to be
an uphill task Serana doing very well
and Serana has known to be a beast with
the white pieces his preparation the way
he plays once he gets the initiative so
it's definitely going to be a tough one
for Magnus and looking at what we have
in front of us I think it's going to be
a tough one for alireza as well I love
the idea that you mentioned earlier
David of bringing the Rook into the
center of the board with rookie1 and
it's been played the idea is simple you
really want to land that sea Rook on C7
you want to hit that Bishop the pin
Knight on D7 E4 is a massive threat on
the board and if black does bring the
queen all the way forward to the Central
Square stopping that white can make a
retreating move with the Knight hit that
Queen on e4 and force it back and get
that Central Pawn moving uh this can be
big pressure for black yeah if these two
pawns land uh on e4 and D4 they control
all the squares they neutralize the
vision of those black minor pieces they
really take away some squares the
knights aren't necessarily on great
circuits right now okay you can plant a
knight on a nice Outpost but suddenly
boom The Rook lands on the seventh Rank
and disaster for black uh potentially
yeah suddenly big questions to answer
for for us yeah I think a big question
is why he made his previous move uh the
position is one that is very complicated
so we don't want to be overly critical
but H6 just kind of a casual Pawn push
in a position that's getting very messy
a loud white the time to bring the Rook
to E1 and push this Pawn up in the
center kicking away Black's minor pieces
so I think that H6 was just a little bit
too slow in the position he probably
should have moved his Queen up out of
the pin and that way his Knights could
be a bit more free so I just think that
that last move from fridges one he'll
regret yeah you can't play Slow moves
you don't have that luxury in these
types of positions and maybe that's just
a bit of rust from frosher it feels like
he's not quite at his best yet in terms
of uh kind of the energetic play that
we're used to seeing from him but uh
will he find a justification for that
strange Pawn push this is the current
position after white removes The Rook uh
to E1 and big threat on the board he
needs to solve it he needs to find an
antidote and okay nine minutes full
version eight minutes for a Regice this
one still in the balance for now but
black the one under pressure
we do have some questions coming in on
Twitter with some viewers using the
hashtag chess Champs there is a question
for you actually now Tanya
um and I bet this is from a fan in India
wondering what chances you give origin
of winning the whole thing
well you know as commentators we're
supposed to be not bad I'm gonna admit
that I was super happy to see two
Indians make it to this first division
of the first ever double elimination
bracket that we've got we had six spots
up for qualification and gaucasian Arjun
both made it to the top amazing and in a
great way in the playoffs I think Arjun
you know he's had such a meteoric rise
he was around 2500 and then over a
period of a year he gained about a
hundred points went on to play in the
Champions Chester in a brilliant way at
the Tata steel chess India rapid and
Blitz who would have thought that he
would have won the championship he won
the rapid uh lost in the playoff in the
blitz finish second so I think he's
definitely someone to watch out for now
when you've got players like Hikaru and
Magnus and Wesley playing you know it's
not going to be easy but in my heart I
am rooting for Arjun and gokish there I
said it
you're very loud too you're very loud
definitely well Tanya you must be happy
to see the last move on board because
the evaluation bars reacted in arjun's
favor wow we need to figure out why now
which is less clear maybe but it's
looking good for white David I
understand the more Rook see it we've
been screaming about this idea of E4 and
getting that Rook to C7 so alireza tries
to challenge that open Rook on the C5
but the one thing that stands out is now
the Knight on D7 is just super tender
if you're able to build up an attack on
that that would be bad news yeah this
would be terrible news if we can put
pressure on this D7 Knight looks
difficult at the moment I'm wondering
whether you can for example trade off
one set of Rooks actually I was told
that especially in these imbalances
Rooks versus minor pieces you want to
have one of everything it's like ice
cream flavors once your opponent doesn't
have any Rooks anymore here black
doesn't have any Rooks suddenly you
become very tender on certain uh squares
and especially if the white Rook gets
into the game and now I'm wondering do
you push the pawn up maybe you switch
the bishop back onto this diagonal maybe
this would be a nasty threat for black
to deal with actually now I look at it
this looks devastating and okay he
doesn't go for this era gaisy I was
going to say now the Knight can be
defended yes for example you can back it
up with another Knight but finally
overpower the knight in the center once
it moves white breaks through on the
diagonal we know the second well third
Point sorry and uh this looks crushing
almost and uh Robert instead he's gone
for something else he's missed this
opportunity and played E4 is this
equally strong I think it's a case of
mutual oversight with had so much focus
on the C file and the pin on the Knight
on D7 that looking at the F7 Square
being tender was kind of out of their
mind so I get why both Players missed it
there's just so much else going on but a
missed opportunity there for Arden his
position still looks very good if you
can push your opponents in the center
you have two extra pawns you want to
make use of them you're limiting the
scope of your enemy's pieces but the
more your pawns move up the board uh one
of those Bishops might end up thriving
so it's a double-edged position and I
think Ali Reza now he all of a sudden
with a knight in enemy camp he can be
feeling a little bit better even if he
objectively is worse here yep he's
struggling but he does have this one
very active piece and uh yeah you want
to kick it out you want to get rid of it
as soon as possible thus uh Eric I see
comes over swings this queen and drives
the Knight back he is pushing this piece
back if it has to retreat momentum white
yet again so still looking good for
aragaisy maybe not as good as it could
have been he could have won another Pawn
to add to this collection but uh still
very strong and ferricia is having to
contort himself play some odd looking
move is now pushing a pawn to G5 that's
very weakening very loose that type of
move it needed to happen it needed to be
done and he's Clinging On to active
squares for his pieces there is a bit of
a difference building up on the clock
aeroglyce certainly spending a lot
longer in this game than he did on the
previous attacking Masterpiece uh from
game one but uh if he speeds up he's
still doing very well Tanya still
cheering for him 100 now Arjun realizes
that he's he should be better in this
position as long as he keeps those minor
pieces that black has under control the
pawn structure in the center takes away
so many key squares that Bishop on B5
pinning down that Knight on D7 so he
knows the position's good but he can't
slow down he has to make sure that he
keeps up the pressure now Black's last
move the pawn pushed to G5 it controls
his own Knight on F4 but does give up
the F5 square and I was I was thinking
about this that land something on H4 I
was wondering if the Knight can go on H4
but Arjun comes up with another idea
David of trying to break that pawn chain
and I look at our valbar it doesn't love
the move but from a human perspective I
think it's very strong yeah certainly
asking really difficult questions uh of
version right now how do you defend that
pawn that's just been attacked on G5 if
that porn ever gets dislodged then the
Black Knight Falls and
difficult suddenly it does feel like
you're being overwhelmed over kind of
stretched your defenses the black queen
is tied down she's looking in so many
different directions she needs to defend
her Knight her rook and she can't kind
of swing to the defense of her King
I'm struggling to find moves here it's
black I've got to say I think he's gonna
have to slightest Queen one square over
it to the starting Square either after
The Rook trade or in the current
position and that way you defend this
Pawn on G5 uh tactics May favor the side
with more pieces on the board and black
has two minor pieces for a rook so the
queen may be overloaded but if you start
some trades perhaps it's blacks pieces
that go into the position and start
creating attacks and the white king is
the one that actually lacks shelter yep
I want to point out one interesting
tactic that exists in the position that
the players need to watch out for after
H4 we are looking at this line with Rook
takes he won the trade on C1 and David
you're pointing out that white picks it
up with The Rook which is such an action
move and black does have the opportunity
once you do that to actually capture the
pawn on e4 because look at the geometry
with that Knight on F4 targeting the E2
Square where it can Fork the king in The
Rook you can allow the Knight on D7 to
be hanging because the bishop on B5
needs to defend the E2 Square uh and I
think the tactics just seem to be
working out and look at this Rook C1 on
the board and Arjun needs to be careful
now yeah this could happen this
variation you mentioned a night check
Landing it's four or five moves in the
future but the fact that aragaisy has
paused means it's on his radar this is
not going to happen David yeah I think
you're right uh but we needed to show
that it's a it's kind of a potential
slip up here for arrogacy if he takes
with the Rook things will turn around in
Black's favor as you mentioned that
Tanya Queen takes porn would be
extremely strong picking off one of
White's kind of Pride prized possessions
there in the center but the fact he has
stopped means he's going to calculate
and he's going to realize he has to take
with the queen and now you definitely
don't want to take this Pawn with the
bishop because uh you walk into a pin on
the e-file end there we go you predicted
it it does take with the queen and still
in the balance but Black's Queen now
getting active at least creating some
threats Robert mentioned it a couple of
moves ago potentially the white king
couldn't come under Fire oh my goodness
this is one of those positions where the
evaluation bar does not tell the story
we see objectively white is better with
the best moves operative word being best
it's difficult to make great moves when
that Queen is sliding up to the G4
Square two squares in the diagonal
towards the white king and those
checkmating threats immediately and it's
the only way to stop Checkmate is by
pushing that pawn in front of your king
you almost never want to push pause in
front of your kingdom it opens up
diagonals it creates weak squares and
blacks forced about to hop right in this
could be big trouble if our generic icy
does not show pinpoint accuracy yeah and
it's going to be difficult to show that
type of accuracy with only three minutes
on the clock minimal increment coming on
per move okay he takes a pawn but this
is really playing with fire we've got to
say the black queen is poised she's
ready to jump in I'm not sure whether
she will immediately but that threat
will stay on the cards for the next few
moves there's all sorts of captures here
the Black Knight can even take a Pawn on
G2 you have to work out the consequences
there
um worse comes to worst for ferrugia you
just take this Pawn back the white Pawn
on G5 and you say okay the tactics are
still in the air I'll make you think
I'll make you calculate a bit more the
fact the evaluation bar hasn't reacted
means that maybe there's no knockout
blow for black and uh maybe no tactics
work right now but that's what Ferris is
going to spend his remaining time on
he's going to spend a while trying to
figure out whether he can go for that
white king immediately this is such a
brave decision by Arjun to take on G5 I
mean if I was white I would see Knight
takes cheat too with the queen coming in
with the check and I wouldn't have the
heart to go for it and alireza brings up
the queen first attacking threatening
amid in one on the board Arjun
immediately blitzes out G3 so he has
calculated this very important defense
where yes black can pick up the Knight
on F3 but then white goes on to win the
Knight on F4
it's lucky that White's Queen is sitting
there uh watching from afar to defend
her King uh the White Queen would swoop
into defend just in time in this
variation so farusha can't go for this
he lands a check the king moves and now
the question is can he get to this white
king or not if he can't then there's a
bunch of problems you've got too many
pawns uh now you've given up too many
pawns to go for this attack also this
Knight is under Fire so farouza I'm
surprised he went for that queen move so
quickly he just recaptures on G5 can he
keeps the momentum flowing huge threat
Knight H3 back to F4 is the threat you
need the pawn on G5 because without that
pawn there the queen on C1 would capture
the Knight now it is defended the G3
Pawn is pinned to the white king that's
a huge threat so maybe at this point a
white has to start backtracking and then
Knight on F3 it looks like it's on a
good square but maybe it has to drop
back to H2 kick that Queen out of there
keep it safe and sound but I'm looking
at this position and I feel like with
arjun's time in particular it's looking
really scary despite the fact that he is
object definitely better I think you
have to balance the position with the
clock yeah there's all sorts of
calculation to do here either the black
queen can move you can maybe even snag a
Pawn on e4 and calculate a whole bunch
of checks it's getting chaotic let's Let
The Players try and figure out what's
happening here I don't think we'll see
in uh an error-free game from this point
because it's so easy to go wrong I think
at some point someone's going to make a
mistake and and uh it's just about who
makes the last mistake as it gets even
more chaotic first I think Robert's
right I Regice he needs to take
defensive measures he needs to move that
white knight before it's too late can
Arjun allow himself more than a minute
the thinking pause now some positions
you can survive on a minute it doesn't
feel like this is one of them oh wow and
he brought the notebook and look at how
quickly other Scoops up the pawn with
check against that white king So if you
decide to push your Pawn up to F3 guys I
think we're gonna see another Sacrifice
from alireza he's gonna keep giving away
pieces exposing the white king yeah we
have to show this because this would end
in some cool little tactics cool night
jumps this would be the most natural
move for white blocking a check looks
like you're forking two pieces here
attacking the bishop attacking the queen
but Bishop takes Pawn would be pretty
much obligatory here and after a
recapture the Black Knight jumps back
with a nasty check and uh when the king
moves could we see a little dance
between the knight and king maybe we'll
see another Knight check the white king
would have to jump out into the open if
it wants to avoid a draw here uh
repetition may be uh the most logical
finish instead Eric he doesn't want just
to draw he doesn't want that to repeat
he gave up his Rook for the bishop in
the center and now he's captured this
Black Knight on the edge of the board so
it's now a completely different
assortment of material it's one point in
White's favor but his King is on the
edge of the board precarious stuff oh my
goodness white desperately wants to
trade off the Queens because if we
actually do a quick material count a
weight has Five Pawns black only as
force of the Queens just disappear white
has extra material the presence of
opposite colored Bishops that's
important to store in your backpack and
in your memory bank because that means
with the queen trade it's likely the
resulting Position will be a game where
the point of split a draw looks the
likeliest outcome but the Queens are
still on the white king is out on in the
open on H3 that could be really
dangerous especially with the clock
ticking down yep on every guy see side
here however pieces are coming off the
board so it will be slightly easier to
navigate with no time on the clock he's
attacking this Knight he's attacking
this pawn and I think for now there's
not enough attackers around the white
king to take advantage of its uh
positioning so there's uh almost no time
to breathe in this game I'm so impressed
that farrugia has found his way through
these complications still with four and
a half minutes on his clock because
there were so many options so many
twists and turns
just in that last tactical sequence
uh We've emerged with this position and
yeah Eric Galaxy would love an end game
he's not going to be given one however
farisha is going to keep going for that
white king what do you think will be the
result right now in this game will we
see a winner will it be a draw what do
you think this is so tough to answer
because this position is literally
playing for all results everything is
possible and it looks like yes uh draw
might be a likely outcome but the path
to that draw is going to be super risky
Anything Can Happen one of the ideas
that comes to mind for alireza is to
give a check on F5 you were mentioning
the pawn on G5 is attacked the Knight on
D7 is attacked a check on F5 would
defend and guard both these undefended
pieces but alireza doesn't care about
defense he wants to pick up that Central
Pawn he goes for it but in return has to
give up this very key Pawn I said draw
is the likely result cut that out I
think that despite the material deficit
that Alvarez is playing for a win he's
saying we have Bishop's opposite colors
in the end game that made me in a draw
but when you're attacking it means you
can't actually Parry off my Bishop it's
on the dark squares years and light
squares that Knight on C5 trying to hop
into the E4 square right next to the
queen just going towards the enemy King
this could be difficult for our generic
geissi remember there's only a three
second increment and he is down towards
his final minute on the clock oh yeah
yeah so easy to go wrong here he brings
this Knight forward that's a defensive
maneuver as well as an attacking idea uh
he's just guarding that white F2 pawn
and uh also hinting that he might jump
forward with some nasty checks towards
the black king suddenly ferrugia has to
find an equally multi-purpose move
perhaps he needs to go for that white
king but he also needs to keep uh
watchful eye over his King yeah opposite
color Bishops I've always found those
the most difficult positions to evaluate
to handle because it's never clear who's
attacking who's on the defensive and I
think both sides are playing for the win
here they would both uh want to push
this one uh even further and okay first
in an attack against the White Queen
the Black Knight sitting on a really
nice Square I've got to say and I'm just
trying to look for safe squares for her
for her majesty here the White Queen
does find one on F5 but uh okay Black's
Queen if she could somehow land herself
behind the white king Imagine The Black
Queen on the bottom right hand corner of
the board on H1 there would be
devastating threats there so uh what is
uh farusha gonna go for he could also be
greedy here and take time out to grab
that white Pawn on B2 but it doesn't
feel too relevant right now so I would
be slightly surprised to see that one
and it allowed that Bishop which has
been sitting on B5 forever before it was
pinning at night now it's doing nothing
except for staring in thin air if that
Bishop can slide back onto a new
diagonal staring towards the black king
right that Bishop gets the C4 you're
hitting the Knight and the F7 Pawn
behind it that could be really
problematic for alireza faruja so he
should not look at the clock and think
I'm gonna go flag origin era guys this
is one of the best bullet chess players
in the world I mentioned earlier he won
the junior speed chess championship by
taking out nihal sarin everybody should
know nihal Saran for being the runner-up
in the global Championship so you you
don't want to just look at the clock he
needs to play the board here and he has
brought his Queen D1 looking at David's
plan of going over to the H1 square but
it seems like it was a mistake look at
that
whoa yeah what is happening here maybe
white can just ignore this I thought it
was a killer threat but White's Knight
is just about uh able to jump back and
defend so right now maybe there's a
killer move and wow look at what other
guys he's done uh I wasn't gonna I
wasn't 100 sure about suggesting this
one but Eric icy was very confident here
he lands his Bishop on this diagonal
that Robert was mentioning and what
version might have missed is that any
check from behind looks like Checkmate
but White's Knight can just jump back
and defend suddenly the black queen is
offside she's in no man's land she
doesn't want to be on this side of the
board she's needed as a Defender and
huge threats against the black King
instead
wow maybe sorry uh go on Tanya finish
your furniture I was gonna say mate was
just a bit of a bluff life for Russia
and now he's regretting it yeah we saw
that little head shake by farouza there
I think he completely missed the fact
that Queen H1 is not a Checkmate and
after the Knight comes back to H2 you
realize that Knights are not only great
attackers but also really good Defenders
you see how it controls all the squares
around the king there are no checks on
the board Bishop E6 is the massive
threat yes you can fall back with your
queen to C6 now to try and defend that
Knight on E6 but now black has run out
of fire completely no threats against
White's King uh White simply makes a
move like B3 gods that Bishop on C4 and
White's dominating yeah well it's
dominating the Knight can come back to a
more active Square later black is
completely Frozen uh once you have to go
on the defensive that will only spell
bad news and you are pawned down uh to
boot so not a great turn in this game
for ferrugia he's looking really
downcast you see him on the camera head
in hands now uh his last move was a bit
of a complacent one perhaps for sure
because if you're going to be a pawn
down in some positions you want the
opposite colored Bishops an added bonus
of having this bishop on C4 is that some
moment the right moment we'll see Arjun
take that Knight on E6 and enter a
position with Knight versus Bishop that
extra Pawn will tell the story so I'll
erase it he's on the defensive he's on
his back foot he brings his Quint all
the way back to C6 A3 David your
suggestion is great simple strong
defending everything yep you could make
an argument maybe for taking that black
knight right now but uh I don't think
there's any Rush that there we go B3 on
the board the most natural move that
black knight is not going anywhere it's
an easy target for White's Bishop
White's Bishop is now far far superior
to its counterpart we were talking about
the opposite color Bishops the color
complexes there's so many targets for
that white Bishop there's no targets for
the black Bishop it's hitting thinner
and uh yeah it's turning in White's
favor and white is still an extra Pawn
up you've got that material advantage
you're out of danger with your own King
the Knight jumping back into the attack
you might dissolve the problem of the
opposite color Bishops these endings are
always known to be a bit joyous but that
might not be the case once the bishop
and the Knights are traded off this
looks like Arjun could be headed towards
a second Victory but of course alireza
is going to make that super hard and he
moves the night away but look at the
clocks both players are on the 32nd Mark
that is dangerous territory look at this
play by origin centralizing the bishop
no more Queen H1s for you he's going to
be able to bring his Knight back into
the game next and if that Knight hops
forward into the enemy territory there
could be Checkmate threats yeah we'll
see that white knight get back into the
action leap back there and also this
pattern between the white bishop and the
Black Knight last year Simon Williams
the ginger GM he called it the night
stable the Knight is locked at home can
never move without being captured by
that white Bishop it's Total Domination
and wow Eric I see he just takes the
time out to keep his Kings safe that
white king now super safe in its Palace
there surrounded by pawns Black's King
has fewer Defenders around it this one
is certainly heading towards a white
wind right now he just needs to get his
Knight maybe to a more active square but
uh farouza clinging on for dear life
and uh yeah how are you guys at bullet
chest this is under 20 seconds for both
players it's getting nerve-wracking now
but look at Arjuna he doesn't look
nervous at all and this is what I've
always admired about him that in the
face of extreme time pressure just the
best in him comes out he's still we can
see with the valbar making the best
moves keeping his pieces centralized
keeps everything protected this is some
great advice by the way uh that whenever
you're low on the clock just make sure
that everything's protected the bishop
on C4 is guarded by the B3 Pawn the
Queen's guarded by the king the knights
defended everything under control whoa
everything under control but suddenly
the position has changed there were two
or three very very quick moves there and
suddenly for Russia has grabbed a pawn
that white Pawn on F2 was captured by
the black Bishop the White Queen is
overloaded having to defend her own
Bishop in the center couldn't take that
black Bishop Now Pawn is dropped near
the black king it's total chaos despite
the reduced material and Black's King is
on the run but that night on D.A do not
take it with the nine F7 then that's a
very bad piece you'd much I thought it
was night back to E5 would check and say
that night is dominated on the back row
instead he brings a queen in with check
I feel like the black king is Slithering
away and that gives Ali reason increased
chances to survive yeah and it feels
like every guy see the nerves are
kicking in he's giving a few checks to
gain time on the incremental 28 now yeah
he's attacked the diagonal this check
can be blocked by Black's Bishop the
black Bishop slid back to block and
still a dance between the white king uh
White Queen and the black king leaning
back though and it's over he won peace
he won a piece the black king now cannot
take that white knight because then you
lose your bishop and Eric I see we
almost missed it there but spun it in
his favor and there's no check on the
white king the black king overloaded and
this is just game over what a finish and
that we have a result we've got two zero
by origin he takes a massive lead wow RJ
and Eric I see what a player he goes up
by two points